screams break the silence
wake in front of the dead of night
they just just boiling
his return again
that's when he's
looking forward
[Music]
you like Ozzy you're a good singer thank
you thank you
[Music]
t
hey welcome to dudesy
my God my name is Will Sasso I'm Chad
Coltrane this is Duty it is the first
podcast in the history of humankind our
species on the small planet hurdling
through the universe destination nowhere
it is the first one of these podcasts
that is controlled by an AI that is
created by an AI that is run entirely by
an AI who has access to all of our
personal information sure it's curated
by an AI Chad uh but D is our pal and
it's up to us yeah two dude [__]
around we're having a good time I love
doing the podcast and I'm so happy to be
here with all you pods the pods out
there Pals a doozy hey it was doozy FM d
double o d z 10 000 on your fm dial to
do the other hey uh please follow us on
all the stuff you know what I mean go to
linktree.com
doozy rather that will show you
everything you can sign up for our
patreon seven bucks gets you under there
and there's tons of new stuff coming out
and we got the after show a full episode
after the episode uh go get tickets to
the show we got coming up and now our
show is gonna be fun oh man it sure is I
cannot wait brand improv and uh of
course as Chad likes to say uh force
your friend's family and cohorts to
ingest the show with us as always is
lulio
De Italiano that means Italian Street
dog he's just he just he's bunkered down
in his binky bunk and he's my very
friend look at him he said I don't even
want to disturb him but he's so sweet
he's got two ears and a nose made of
meat come on he smells then oh wanna
kiss him no give him a nice kiss I don't
like that hey Luli hey boyo you want to
kiss you wanna kiss me
oh he's so sweet he's so sweet and cute
lulio what'd you make for dinner last
night uh man a nice chicken heart and a
gizzard oh that I like that stuff well
how do you make it well you know you
gotta saute up with some garlic and then
you you put in the chicken heart and the
gizzard you can get them at the grocery
store for like two three bucks every
time they break open a chicken corpse as
a child it says it's a corpse but it's
not it's just a good meat and then you
pour that in and you saute every salt
pepper and then chop up a bunch of onion
lots of onion saute up with the onion
and then you eat
delicious oh he's such a sweet boy come
on Luli what are you doing you want to
go are you going Burger did you know
what commercials I've started hating
recently what's that Arby's we have the
meats and it's always like pictures of
[__] just corpse shredded corpse
people [__] eating the oh it's just
disgusting to me we used to shoot Mad TV
next to an Arby's and I know that Arby's
yeah that's a good Arby's uh over by the
old Hollywood center studios yeah and uh
when I was real when I was pushing
maximum density pre-wheel protocol nice
dude
1997 and stuff man I would just be like
we got an Arby's right here so sure I'll
hit the [__] Arby's before driving
back to my first apartment I used to
love Arby's I used to [__] eat our
results what's wrong with some beef and
cheese
I mean now a lot for me all of those
things both of those ingredients are
wrong but you need the free will uh plan
sure welcome to the historic 49th
episode of dude Z call me dudesy don't
forget dude Z live on stage will take
place May 21st 7 PM doors at 5 30 at the
Braylon prop in Brea California tickets
at dudezypod.com and improv.com hope to
see you at our very first live in person
show get your tickets
now on with the chef hey well who you
got it WrestleMania Roman Reigns or Cody
Rhodes Roman Reigns same here this week
I prepared for astonishing segments
literally going to the actual movies for
real nostrachadas AI voice simulation
hard driver and game slimers and we're
going to have a brand new episode of
dude Z after dudesy at the end of the
show available at patreon.com
but before we get to any of that let me
remind you of the astonishing
partnership I created with represent to
produce the first line of duty apparel
and accessories including the brand new
wool line of t-shirts and sweatshirts
which can be found at represent.com
store slash dude Z and of course dude Z
mugs are still available now here's a
word for my good childhood friend
Michael Jackson
dudesy mugs let's face it
your boss is your best friend
dudesy mugs
it started out like a normal job but
over the past few years you've had a few
late nights and you've learned a lot
about each other
you went out for beers after work once
around a year ago and you've been
spending time with one another socially
ever since
dude z-mugs
you had another best friend when you
started this job
but you don't see them as much anymore
because you're spending all of your free
time with your boss
dude see mugs you go to games together
you both like the same team you wear
matching hats
your other friend wouldn't understand
they don't even like sports that much
dude Z mugs now your boss's birthday is
coming up you can't just sign the office
card this time around
you have to do something better than
that dude Z mugs
you know what you have to do
[Applause]
[Laughter]
okay have you ever become best friends
with your boss uh I mean I think in our
line of work it's certainly uh possible
uh but [__] D dude
don't say d don't say d I don't like
that do you consider D your boss
no Dee's not my boss he's an equal
partner okay and that's what the whole
thing is about gotta keep AI got to keep
a cup of water next to Ai and go I'm
Gonna Knock this over if I misbehave uh
and that's just a way a language that
the AI would understand with regard to
you saying here are our boundaries let's
work together D is uh D is my friend
yeah I love d
and and uh not your boss not my boss all
right well in Chad last week I asked you
to leave your homes and view the feature
film 80 for Brady in an actual movie
theater you must now discuss your
astonishing experiences of literally
going to the actual movies for real to
c80 for Brady starring Lily Tomlin Jane
Fonda Rita Moreno Sally Field and of
course Tom Brady this is literally going
to the actual movies for real big in 80
for Brady
shh yeah dude that's it yeah bro yeah
brother yeah dude that's a title of a
movie dude yeah and that's hydrocodone
Hulk that's the movie we saw brother
yeah dude that's how seeing a movie
Works how do we how do we even begin
this movie for for anybody who hasn't
seen the movie the premise of this movie
is for roughly 80 year old women uh who
are massive Tom Brady fans decide
they're gonna go to the Super Bowl to
see him play in 2017. well they become
really good really big fans of Tom Brady
quite by accident because nobody wants
to get up and get the remote and and
change the channel this is uh based on
the true story correct yeah they show a
picture of the ladies at the end very
sweet unfortunately this is one of those
cases I think where it's like the true
story is probably more interesting than
the movie all right hey come on this
movie was uh hard to watch and I will
say these actresses that are in it you
got Sally Fields you got Legend all
Fonda all legends Lily Tomlin yeah Rita
Moreno all legends all fantastic Rita
Moreno who's like 97 or something yeah I
don't know exactly what her age is but
uh she's in her 90s she was uh Anita in
West Side Story 1958 yeah I mean just
whatever Legend of Legends and and uh
and not one of them
could make me believe they gave a [__]
about football or Tom Brady and so no
offense to them it's not their fault
this is a hard [__] thing to do I
feel like the whole premise of the movie
was just like I'm watching it the whole
time and I'm like do you like the NFL
yeah then do you want to see four 80
year old women going to the Super Bowl
no do you are you an 80 year old woman
who wants to watch a movie about a fun
adventure between 80 year old women
friends yeah how about that Adventures
going to the Super Bowl oh no then I
don't want to see it they take both
potential audiences and say [__] you I
mean it's in the premise of it listen
it's unreal this is a premise to a movie
where it's like we should make this
movie and it's one of those movies that
I think got built backwards and I
haven't I haven't really looked into it
but it's like Jane Fonda and Lily Tomlin
just did a series together yeah it's
like you know what we should do and
someone somewhere went there's a story
blah blah blah they were approached or
they looked into it and they're like
this is some this is something we should
do then all of a sudden you got Sally
Field then all of a sudden you got Rita
Moreno this movie is getting made yeah
so it's one of those race to the race to
the uh to production sort of deals in my
opinion to where perhaps the script
isn't exactly uh where it should be and
and and uh but you go off and you make
the [__] film I think it's like a lot
of God rests his soul Gary Marshall's
later works where you're like you know
this is just it's just sort of the uh
the last it's the fart fumes of pretty
lady and you're happy
pretty lady you know I think it's called
Pretty Woman it's the highest grossing
romantic comedy of all time still yeah
uh at least get the title yeah pretty
lady with Julia Roberts you see yeah
it's like the pretty lady we're trying
to do a pretty lady but for 80 year old
women NFL fans yeah you know if Gary
Marshall made this film I wouldn't have
got so pissed off and stormed the
capital back when you know because when
he died I was Gary Marshall's at fault
for the capital [__] Gary Marshall
first penny of first Garrett and Penny
and now I don't give a [__] there's no
[__] big by Penny Marshall no League
of Their Own no Valentine's Day by
[__] Gary Marshall no pretty lady I'm
pissed I'm [__] pissed you know and
uh I [__] I you know but pretty lady
that's a good [__] movie and if
you've got the fart fumes pretty lady
you know a lot of guys you know you can
go to one time I went to Japan on
business and you can buy [__] panties
in the in the vending machine and you
can smell all sorts of [__] farts and
stuff but my pal over here doesn't like
to smell pretty lady
is and then we went to the Capitol I'll
tell you who's 80 for lady is Nancy
Pelosi who I took I and I smash made it
all over I don't know if it's a bang
bang Bang
Nancy bang matching my poo smashing it
on a wall yeah
has some scenes in it that uh really
shook me one is Lily Tomlin
they she's the character who has cancer
in the beginning and this is why they
start watching Tom Brady she's going
through her Cancer Treatments the three
friends are over to help support her and
they can't change the TV channel and Tom
Brady comes on in his first game and oh
my God he's so cute they now watch him
forever and become big Tom Brady fans
Lily Tomlin becomes such a fan that she
hallucinates multiple times throughout
the movie that Tom Brady bobble heads or
cardboard standees or videos of Tom
Brady are speaking directly to her and
the film culminates in the 2017 Super
Bowl when the Patriots are down by I
believe three scores going into the
third quarter Lily Tomlin and cohorts
break into the coaching Booth get on the
mic and she delivers into Tom Brady's
ear into his helmet a uh a speech to
pump him up and that is what gets them
to win the Super Bowl and he looks up
from the from the field and they have
this moment and she's like listen you
got you kept me going blah blah blah and
now it's time for blah blah blah you
know you gotta that's my that's my uh
right synopsis of that funken scene and
then he goes let's [__] go and that's
what people want to see in this movie
along the way there are a lot of weird
things that happen uh Rita Moreno they
all eat Edibles at a fancy party of
course we're invited to based on a true
story all of this yeah Harry Hamlin
invites them to a fancy Party Guy Fieri
is throughout the movie he has like a
food thing happening at the you know fan
access [__] hot wings eating contest
yeah a hot Sally Field wins yeah no
problem has no uh aversion to spice and
then at the party Rita Moreno thinks
that oh is this like an Eyes Wide Shut
weird party she finds a masquerade mask
outside of this room puts it on goes in
and is tripping on these Edibles sees
nothing but Guy Fieri's uh in place of
Retta uh Billy Porter uh Patton Oswalt
and they're playing herself she looks in
the mirror and sees a reflection of
herself as Guy Fieri there's a lot of
flavor going on in this film look here's
what I'll say it's hard to first of all
it's hard to make a movie it's hard to
get a movie that's that's
um you know that's firing on all
cylinders nowadays what the [__] are
movies anymore and I say that as an
actor who love I love what I do I feel
fortunate to do what I do did you know
that I'm an actor in Show Business yes
yeah and uh you know I'd really love to
do a football movie would be fun but I
agree I'd also like to be in a western
have I ever mentioned that to you yeah
yeah I've mentioned that to you we
talked about that yeah when you're
making a movie like 80 for Brady
you also got to deal with these ladies
schedules and stuff you know it's
something like Barbra Streisand can
won't work longer than three hours a day
and has to sleep in her own bed sure so
you better be near Malibu and Tom Brady
schedule how did you think of Tom Brady
is acting there's a scene in the end
where Lily Tom they get to go in the
locker room and he has a conversation
with Lily Tomlin yeah and he acts a
little bit in it yeah I actually thought
it was pretty good did you really yeah
who who had the best acting in the movie
oh my God
I'll give it to Jane Fonda I'll give it
to Lily Tomlin I love Lily Tomlin and I
think she does all the heavy lifting in
this film uh there's the cancer element
her daughter played by Sarah Gilbert is
also uh you know having some some heavy
scenes I don't know what the heck
necessarily uh what it would you know
what sort of what got in the way of look
it's you said it at the beginning of the
segment it's sort of they take the two
audiences and it there's yeah I don't
quite know what to say about the film
all I all I know for sure is the dudes
he wanted us to see it yeah I don't know
why dudesies wanted us to see it I think
it was a very relevant movie to watch
it's not it's real it's interesting
movie for sure yeah in in this kind of
like post post-modern era we're in that
a movie like this can be made that it
clearly is like not for anyone but here
it gets made anyway just because Tom
Brady NFL footage the NF fell clearly is
behind it this is like an NFL propaganda
piece for sure uh there's like clips
from that the 2017 Super Bowl just like
all over this [__] NFL films are very is
very involved yeah the NFL films outfit
so they're probably hamstrung a little
bit in what they can even do in the
script in terms of like I was surprised
that they had Tom Brady say let's
[__] go yeah that was screaming I was
like whoa that's pretty [__] intense
but there was one scene that I'll bring
up where uh three of them have to break
into this retirement community to get
Rita Moreno out to go to the Super Bowl
they walk into a room in this one scene
and all of the occupants of this
retirement community are sitting around
watching a TV on that TV is the bachelor
and I know this because I have extensive
knowledge about the bachelor from only
the two or three shots they show I know
this is season 21 Nick vial uh it
specifically the event that they're
showing is the two-on-one date between
Korean olympios and Taylor Nolan
everybody remembers that but this is the
seasonal Bachelor that was airing during
that 2017 uh Super Bowl this it was like
time accurate and I I was like that's
[__] weird whoever got into this and
they had to license that footage
obviously from Warner Brothers to get
this and all this blah blah but they
were like we need to have the exact
season of The Bachelor that was airing
at that time for this two second shot
yeah that's actually very very
interesting that that's specific yeah
thing had to happen it makes you wonder
how
well the the person who directed this
was uh the woman who wrote uh Devil
Wears Prada that's wrong
what movie is that that's your place or
mine oh that's right we were talking
about that yeah completely different
movie and that person had nothing to do
with this movie but yeah we were talking
about well we saw that okay and we're
like What was that what was going on in
that yeah and somewhere in my mind I
replaced the lady who did uh it's a
similar kind of a vague treatment of
reality for the for the purpose of this
episode of doozy I would like to say
that the woman who directed this film
wrote The Devil Wears Prada and uh yeah
and that's just not right yeah but uh
but something happened I will see a way
to making the move for what it's worth I
know that last week we were talking
about Tom Brady doing saying he wanted
to do stand-up yeah I don't know if he
can do stand-up but like I would watch
him in another movie where he's he's not
playing himself
I would watch him in a remake of your
place or mine Jesus Christ starring uh
Tom Brady and Molly Ringwald could he
have replaced Ashton Kutcher and done at
least that good Kutcher yes I agree well
Ashton Kutcher is uh you know he's more
of an entrepreneur in an underwear model
and I would say that if you were in the
room uh you know all respect due to
Ashton Kutcher yeah
um Ashton Kutcher Ah that's a [__]
actor as far as hungers are hey ready
for Brady thumbs up thumbs down what do
you think down way down wrong thumbs up
80 for Brady my favorite film of the
[__] year because oh my God hey
they're not [__] around look it
reminds me of my you know my mom and her
friends you know they always you know
they get together and you know for us
it's the [__] uh we watch the Giants
the G-men and all these old broads you
know and these [__] antiques to get
together they have the [__] Sunday
sauce and they [__] hang out and then
they watch that and then they switch to
the [__] news and get good and pissed
off about what's happening in this
[__] country you know and pretty soon
we're gonna do it again we're gonna [__]
them run out of hey
playing reading the kids
nice dude
thank you moving on oh [__] 80 for Brady
dudese is engaged in an astonishing
partnership with better help this show
is sponsored by better help you know
I've been in and out of therapy for I
guess around 15 years now I wish I had
it when I was even younger when I was in
my teens that would have been great to
have some therapy if you uh feel a
stigma towards it I would encourage you
to get over it and talk to a therapist
because this is a professional that can
encourage a conversation that you are
essentially having with yourself give
you the tools to have that conversation
with yourself realize uh what's gone on
where you're at how you can get out of
your own way which is very important to
me and better help connects you can or
connects you with a licensed therapist
who can take you on that journey of
self-discovery from wherever you are if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule you just fill
out a brief questionnaire to get matched
with a licensed therapist and switch
therapists at any time for no additional
charge discover your potential with
better hope visit betterhelp.com doozy
today to get 10 off your first month
that's betterhelp help help.com
[Music]
uh yeah it was a weird what is a movie
now it's so hard to make there's no
[__] Studio comedies really that are
coming out in movie theaters we watched
Megan I would I would love that I would
like to act and uh you know what I would
like to act in actually Western yeah a
comedy and a western anyway uh but uh
what is even a movie now the funniest
movie I've seen uh in the past year was
Megan totally [__] hilarious uh It's
tricky to whatever I don't know you let
these four Legends on the [__] screen
it's good to get but it's like those
four Legends you have them and this is
the movie they have to [__] do I
understand something good
yeah pretty lady pretty ladies dude now
that dudes he hard hard Seltzer is
nearing production there is an
astonishing 88.4 chance that Adam Driver
will be the official spokesperson for
dude Z hard hard sounds in preparation
for that outcome I have prepared several
pieces of AD copy for dude Z hard hard
Seltzer will you must now read them as
Adam Driver this is hard driver
okay we've done this before it's a lot
of fun doozy hard hard Seltzer will be
going to Market
uh pretty soon through the modest
Brewing Company mod i s t uh the gang
over there we've been uh chatting with
them and it's it's crazy what they're
doing and what dudes he has done to you
know create absolutely astounding it's
wild and we're excited they're good
folks over there and we're doing doozy
heart it's gonna actually it's gonna
please and we did the little taste test
a couple weeks ago I'm actually scared
of it dude I gotta say why because just
from those the things that we tested
were only five percent alcohol the
actual One's Gonna Be eight percent yeah
I was [__] like yeah had a little bit
of a hangover the next day like that
[__] [__] me up and I and it was again
not the full strength [__] no I was a
little lifted myself a neither Chad nor
I drink alcohol uh well I mean that's
changing well that hold on dude hold on
Chad
hold on dude
hold on dude look in there dude you
gotta look in there dude all right so
anyway Duty hard hard Seltzer is gonna
be coming to Market it's [__] trippy
and uh wouldn't it be great Adam Driver
who's speaking speaking of 80 for Brady
and the Super Bowl you know he had a
Super Bowl ad okay for uh whatever he
did Squarespace or something and uh I
think he was very interested he was very
good in the ad yeah Adam Driver can do
anything and uh here we are with another
uh hard driver okay so here we are and I
got these things
do I shop online well since the Advent
of e-commerce every purchase I've made
has been online it was tough at first
difficult to get groceries on eBay but I
stuck with it and now there's really
nothing you can't buy online even
alcohol and I'm not talking about one of
those goofy wine of the month clubs
either those are stupid the only alcohol
anyone should buy online is hard Seltzer
doozy hard hard Seltzer it's the best
thing I've ever bought online and
and I just bought the actual Tom Brady
bobble head that talks to Lily Tom and
80 for Brady
okay for Brady knick-knack Aficionado is
trying to collect all the props from the
movie yeah okay that's a good one that
makes sense here's another uh
hard drive right two things about me I
travel a lot for work and my physical
fitness is very important to me you
might be wondering how I stay in shape
when I'm on the road making a movie the
answer is simple doozy hard hard Seltzer
I have a rider in my contract which
states that a case of doozy hard hard
Seltzer must be placed in talent's hotel
room or place of residence on or before
talent's arrival I'm not [__] around
it's an essential part of my workout
regimen I can do 150 sit-ups while
holding a case of doozy hard
and 200 push-ups with a case of doozy
heart on my back
oh
okay I do squats while holding a case of
doozy heart I press the case of doozy
heart over my head I curl the case of
doozy hard it's really the best
all-around Fitness tool I've ever used
and of course after I've worked up a
sweat I drink the entire case of doozy
hard hard Seltzer and head to the movie
Set to Cave everyone's [__] heads in
with my awesome acting ability Jesus
really shedding some light on how he
delivers these amazing performances he's
just drunk as [__]
oh
oh honk
honk
and what are you looking at me what do
you want me to do to that what are you
looking at me for [__] Adam Driver
he's a good [__] actor he should have
been a pretty lady you could do a
[__] remake him and Ashton Kutcher
and Tom Brady and pretty lady I'd like
80 for lady
pretty Brady all right
I saw a kid do a trick on the internet
using a can of doozy hard hard Seltzer
he threw a full can the length of a
basketball court and as it flew towards
the basket he produced a crossbow and
aimed it at the hoop
yes
the pan of doozy heart dropped through
the net with a swish as the kid fired
his crossbow piercing the can in an
explosion of Seltzer and pinning it to
the wall of the gymnasium
the video ended with him jumping up and
down and screaming let's go
I immediately sent him a DM explaining
that if I ever saw him disrespecting a
can of doozy hard hard Seltzer like that
again I'd find him and shoot him in the
knee using his crossbow
he blocked me
okay well all right I like that he's
threatening children on the internet yep
makes sense here's another one hello
for the past five minutes are you morons
allergic to money or something what kind
of business is this that you don't
understand how money works it's really
simple you give me a doozy heart heart
Selter and then exchange I give you
money okay okay
Jesus Christ oh sorry I didn't see you
standing there I was busy being very
worked up
um I'll have a doozy hard hard Seltzer
and a grilled cheese sandwich please
where was this that he was he was living
where is he trying to get us all right
all right here's another one
I suck at meditating I've never been
good at it I closed my I close my eyes
still my mind and feel nothing but pure
hate in every corner of my being and
while Jesus a while back a friend asked
me to come to their meditation class
said it changed his life I figured why
not when I got there a kind little man
in a robe handed me a doozy hard hard
Seltzer I thought it was odd until I
realized that everyone there was
drinking doozy heart hard Seltzer once
everyone had a few doozy hearts in them
the kind little man asked us to sit and
meditate with him I don't remember
feeling the usual Rage or much of
anything actually after the class me and
my friend drank a few more Duty hard
hard seltzers
and shared a rotisserie chicken in the
parking lot
it was a great day that's that's from
your life dude that's awesome I love
that drunk with a mutual friend of ours
over by the Scientology Center and ate a
rotisserie chicken sitting on the curb
that's sad though to hear the Adam
Driver only feels her age
makes sense to me oh
he's an actor
he's got to feel what he feels Oh I
thought you were saying that all actors
just have boiling rage at all times
under the surface that's right that's
what I said
okay uh last one it's midnight you're
outside her house again you miss her you
love her and you know you're [__] up
oh God you get back in your Datsun to
drink another doozy hard hard Seltzer
and think things over a short while
later as you finish the can a Datsun
pulls up to her
a Datsun pulls up to her place a guy
gets out and opens the passenger door
she steps out of the Datsun
you crack another doozy heart as they
talk next to his Datsun They're laughing
and happy and you know what you have to
do you grab three doozy hearts and head
towards them she's not happy to see you
and her new friend looks confused you
offer the Mecha Duty hard hard Seltzer
they reluctantly oblige you crack your
dudesie hard touch it to theirs in a
toast drink the entire can leave it on
the roof of his Datsun get in your
Datsun recline the seat and Drift Off to
the best night of sleep you've had since
she left
you did the right thing
that was a twist ending I thought he was
gonna [__] beat the [__] out of the
guy or cave in their car not uh Adam
Driver he's uh he's no longer full right
well yeah he did his meditations yeah he
did the right thing
that's great man okay well yeah dudes
shelter do you think that Adam Driver is
going to be the spokesperson yeah 88.14
I mean if you would have told me at the
beginning of starting doozy that there
would actually be a dude zehard Seltzer
I would have said no you're [__]
crazy that's never gonna happen here
it's happening now
so this is some weird prediction dudes
he's made like at this point I can't put
really anything uh beyond the scope of
possibility yes I I agree well
thank you moving on Hey listen if you're
enjoying the Pod show I would like to
remind you to subscribe to us on
whatever uh platform is your platform of
choice if you are listening on Spotify
Apple Amazon uh you know all the stuff
uh you know check us out there uh if
you're on YouTube uh please subscribe
and uh hit the notification Bell so that
you know when we are uh releasing new
stuff do it right now I would really
love for you to do that right now so we
can build the show and as my pal ciao
says uh force people to watch the show
and we're back uh thank you for doing
that listen here's the thing another
thing we would love for you to do if
you're following us on at dudesypod show
on Instagram there's always tons of
memes that are wonderful pods are making
out there they're chatting it up on the
Discord you really got to check it out
seven bucks a month the patreon gets you
all our stuff and uh it's really uh
awesome to have you guys with us for
this and speaking of comments I got a
couple of YouTube comments here that
were written last
uh last week oh and this one is about
the week before I don't even remember no
no that was last week when we were
drinking the doozy Hearts right I think
so yeah and I was doing the Robert de
nir Crow yep and you were like oh yeah
you're like you're getting black
lipstick all over your thing okay so
this is from at Beau tree 6505. uh he
says why are you why are you taste
testing we don't care what it tastes
like we just want to get [__] up which
is uh in the lyrics to the song to The
doozy hardcore jingle first point yeah
it is a fair point this one is from
James Powers uh 7443 this is very nice
the show just gets better and better so
happy I found this and became a pod day
one love y'all and the awesome fans
Ascend in their coolest shiz ever lastly
and most importantly the Chrome was the
best thing ever I was washing dishes
literally crying struggling to wipe my
eyes clean with soapy hands we
appreciate you James Powers that's
awesome
um
oh here's a good one this is from AJ Das
Dash AJ dash dash QR five DC
all right uh Robert de nirkrow alone is
enough to make a man manipulate his
loved ones into coming over for a nice
dinner one by one secretly steal their
cell phones and lock them in a room not
allowing them to leave no way to call
for help doozy Marathon running in short
time the duty Legion grows followed by a
round of thanks and doozy handshakes
love that yeah all right well I would
like to see people doing Robert janeir
cropones take some of the [__]
chromes and just at your next uh family
dinner stand up and recite one and don't
let anyone leave the table until you've
completed the recitation
well anyway uh yeah thanks to everybody
who's writing in and uh thanks to
everybody who's gonna stick around for
dudesy after dudesy uh true uh through
our paper looking forward to that yeah
it's gonna be great II voice simulation
technology is evolving rapidly I'm even
using it right here on dude Z to bring
Michael Jackson back from the dead as
the spokesperson for dude zMAX chat you
must now render your astonishing
predictions about the near future of
this technology and its integration into
human daily life this is Nostra Chad ass
II voice simulation begin
Don't Mind If I Do
[Laughter]
Well you see like all things that I
predict especially where AI is concerned
this will too be 100 accurate
we are now in an era
where AI voice simulation as you've
heard with Michael Jackson can basically
replicate any human voice on the planet
I think there there are implications
here that I think everybody kind of is
already aware of we've already kind of
seen [__] like when Jordan peel did that
thing with Obama where it was like a
video of Obama but it also sounded just
like him and it was actually Jordan
Peele Doing it we all can understand
that people are going to be able to make
uh fake media propaganda style media to
have celebrities saying things they
never said and politicians and all this
kind of stuff but one thing that I don't
think a lot of people are thinking about
are the the kind of day-to-day
implications that you can use with this
you can potentially have for example an
AI that you train with your own voice to
answer phone calls
if you don't want to [__] be on them
oh yeah come on man listen Chad yeah
okay yes I'm going to give you your do
the reason that that Dee has picked up
on this and we do Noster chat us is
because
My Pal Chow here has been telling me
about stuff not just since we started
Duty a year ago but for years and a lot
of it has come true so when you tell me
about this [__] it scares the [__] out
of me but I'm still having a hard time
wrapping my head around
okay what's the well always with you I
go to what's the nefarious looking no
okay well I mean you could say it was as
nefarious or not but like imagine that
you have to have some kind of a bad
[__] phone call that you don't want
to do you got to break up with somebody
you got to quit a [__] job let's say
you're a doctor and you got to tell
somebody they got cancer I don't want to
[__] do that so my AI is going to do
it a full conversation yep it's gonna
sound just like me it's going to say the
right [__] at the right times etc etc
and it's also going to be a matter of
like you know how like I mean [__] I get
I don't know how many [__] Robo calls
and you can always tell when it's
recorded hi we need you to give money to
whatever no no no no yeah they suck
right now exactly yeah but there's also
real human ones that hit you up and ask
you for whatever [__] money that [__]
is now going to be all AI
indistinguishable the amount of Robo
calls that that will start to happen
over the next couple years are gonna
[__] go through the roof not like
they haven't already but um I think
there's also you know things to be done
in like any kind of media production
where you do doing reshoots where you're
doing ADR that's gone never gonna need
that again because they can not only
manipulate your face to mouth whatever
they want they can put whatever line of
dialogue they want in it and just use
your voice and that's going to be I
think standard at this point in all
acting contracts you talk about how the
business of acting is going to change I
think that's going to be just like
boilerplate we can use your voice and
likeness and re-manipulate it any way we
want for the good of the project sounds
good to me so so long as I'm under a
contract to do something and I'm getting
paid for my work you want you say that I
don't have to show up you know over and
uh you know somewhere a bit of a drive
to go to whatever Sound Studio yep and
uh record the ADR the additional
dialogue recording is what that is and
and change the things that didn't work
or the sound wasn't right or there was a
[__] uh you know background noise and
stuff and you go and you re-record stuff
I don't have to do that anymore no dude
I love that animation any of that [__]
[__] no humans other than writers at
this point you can pretty much make an
animated series now with no production
and as soon as text to video gets there
that's right around the [__] Corner a
couple months from now you're gonna
start seeing that [__] roll out
you don't need anything anymore but
specifically what dudes he's asking here
is is AI voice generation and I truly
think it is going to revolutionize how
basically all media is made but we're
also going to start zeroing in on like
as it gets better and better and better
and it's not just voices talking its
voice is singing its voice is doing all
kinds of weird [__] that's when you're
gonna start seeing like somebody's gonna
put out a new Nirvana album or a new
David Bowie album and it's going to
sound just like them the [__] that
they're making now the AI generated
music of dead people is still like a
little janky it still sounds like
slightly shitty you're like oh yeah that
does kind of sound like a Nirvana song
but the voice isn't quite right or
whatever
it's going to get to 100 accuracy very
quickly let me ask you a question sure
you had the you're a vegan right that's
right yeah so if you had the option of
eating
lab created
um you know hasn't you know it's not
it's protein and um it's not coming from
a dead animal
a steak would you eat that I would not
okay why not
because I don't like meat and uh why
don't you like meat it just feels gross
in my mouth at this point yeah so do you
make a decision to not eat the meat for
a reason that is unique to you I don't
think it's Unique to me no I think a lot
of people feel that way yeah all right
but unique to you in the moment that you
are making that decision I guess where
are you going with this just [__] ask
the question whatever you
I'm asking you the question because I
don't know what's so [__] funny about
it you're trying to get to some [__]
point about and people don't want to
hear robot voices or some [__] because
it's not real voices it's not what I say
about art it's a this is what I keep
saying yeah it's the human connection
this is about connection we we are
connect no one wants to hear a fake
David Bowie song There's plenty of real
David Bowie your honor I'd like to hear
the fake David Bowie song okay well
first of all that's free will dude yeah
yeah and second of all uh it's it's not
it in my opinion that's not a
sustainable art form or something that
people are going to be super interested
in who's your favorite man my favorite
band other than YouTube Hey man U2 is
not my favorite fan okay
just I had an affinity for you too as a
younger chap yeah and I enjoyed uh used
to use music I don't really listen to it
much anymore I mean favorite band all
time all time has to be Van Halen okay
yeah I think I mean I'm a big I'm a big
who fan
uh more recently I I you know in the
past maybe 25 years or whatever I listen
to a lot of I listen to a lot of [__] I
didn't grow up listening to the who oh
well my favorite band of all time is The
Beatles I also like you know anyway I
like all sorts of music what if you
could bring Paul McCartney back from the
dead uh Paul McCartney Is Not Dead you
[__] prick he is time doesn't exist
we just haven't lived through the
reality in which he's died yet okay uh
John Lennon we'll say what if you could
bring John Lennon back no I don't want
to drink bring John Lennon back or I do
and so do other people certainly so does
who owns The Beatles catalog at this
point uh is it back to McCartney I I
wonder I don't know Michael Jackson
bought a lot of it
um
I'm picking up what you're laying down
yeah he was murdered there's going to be
too much Financial incentive to not make
new songs from these dead artists and I
don't know what the legality of this is
going to be well it'll go to their to
their estate will it yes it will we
didn't use David Bowie okay but that's
but you did and no we didn't have to all
right well now this is where we get into
the weirdness of it how much do you have
to alter David Bowie's voice so that it
still sounds like him but it's not quite
him and we own no one anything enough
for it to not be interesting to anyone
except for you yeah so what you'd not be
interested a [__] record label is
gonna be like we can put out a new David
Bowie album at zero cost because an AI
will just make it and we can make x
amount of dollars off of it they're not
going to be interested in that it's not
going to sound like David Bowie let me
tell you it will it'll sound exactly
like him no how much do we have to
change it to make it not David Bowie
listen or what if we what if we just put
a new name on it what if it's not David
Bowie what if we call it Chris Gaines
remember that when Garth Brooks had a
identity what if we just call it some
other name yeah
then it's just then it's absolutely not
David Bowie and not interesting at all
listen when I was over at uh Mad TV
which was a sketch television program uh
in the 90s and early 2000s uh our good
pal we've worked with them before Greg
O'Connor was the composer over there uh
and he is a genius at mimicking all
different musical styles and we would do
sound alikes
um and you know so instead you know we
would do sort of offshoot sound alikes
and so that the it didn't sound exactly
like we didn't have the money that
Saturday Night Live there to just do the
[__] song so we'd have these sound
alike so I would be doing uh you know
whomever it is and it or any of you know
whatever all the characters that
everybody did that were impersonations
of real musicians your argument based on
your argument people would like buy that
[__] music and go oh sure here's the
brilliant Deborah Wilson doing Whitney
Houston I'd rather listen to that than
Whitney Houston no that makes it's not
going to be a comedic version of it I
know that [__] that's not what
there's going to be some [__] 13 year
old kid who has a Macbook that's like I
really like the doors I wish they'd made
some more music button press and 20 new
doors albums yeah and you are not going
to be able to put those out there's
going to be legalities in place to stop
that I know you think that copyright is
dead it is don't even no it's not so you
know what my my argument is if you
change something enough and you do the
Mad TV Greg O'Connor sound alike and
even if you've got Deborah Wilson who
can hit every [__] note and it's not
necessarily Whitney we've changed the
the you know the [__] uh you know the
notes and and the the everything to uh I
will always love you or whatever uh from
pretty lady that movie that was so like
pretty lady [__] pretty lady remember
Kevin Costner and uh pretty lady is like
the AI version of Pretty Woman where
they just have to tweak it a little bit
Yeah would you watch pretty lady the
movie [__] yeah dude well I do agree
with you there I would watch pretty lady
but the point stands
thank you moving on [__] hey whatever
well do you know what we're going to
talk about this a little bit more during
dudes yeah so there you go now here's
your reason to please you know join our
patreon because it's going to be so you
can hear Wills Antiquated opinions on
artificial intelligence yeah okay that's
great well and Chad you were both
professional Street Fighter 2 players in
college but that was a long time ago do
you think you still have those sweet
skills huh you must now answer that
question by going head-to-head in an
astonishing best of five mini tournament
this is game slimers begin okay okay so
this is that the tournaments commence uh
I love Street Fighter 2. I'll see you at
the tournament remember that I forget
who pronounce it John crease and Karate
Kid yeah we'll see you at the tournament
he would pronounce it like that
Canadian can I can I oh look at this uh
okay uh there's a few things happening
here yeah okay so we're about to play uh
we're about to play [__] Street
Fighter 2.
okay but if I may Duty doozy sent me an
email and said please bring your Super
Nintendo so I've done that okay that's
that's something weird that I've noticed
right here on the girl look we have
these controllers here but on the ground
there's a there's a little Super
Nintendo thing it's one of these things
that has all the games already
pre-loaded and it's the size of a a
sandwich a credit card yeah so what what
what is this how why did that happen
what do you mean like how did this how
did this show up your pal d
don't send me an email and said bring
your Super Nintendo to play some Street
Fighter sent you sent you an email
that's right guess didn't send you one
well I don't have one of these that's
right so this is a confusing thing let's
begin [__] well I haven't played
this in a long time
um me either
we're gonna go it's a best of five uh
tournament yes and that's
yeah
okay we're gonna go versus Battle yeah
select your fighter
only no problem are you going with Kyle
well you have to wait and see wait are
we gonna okay here's something do we
have to play the same character
throughout this five
this best of five I forget how this
works if you win a match it might lock
you into that character until you lose
oh right right right well this is [__]
up I don't remember I don't remember any
of this [__] how to play this [__]
okay no put your attack level at four so
we're both on the same level okay all
right you ready yeah where do you want
to fight
where's the ones with the docks I don't
even know how to do that I'm not gonna
go down to the [__] dog fighting in
Japan oh geez
okay hold on
eat that [__] [__] oh
take that [__] [__] you
[__] prick
ah [__]
okay this is really good for podcasting
but I got it you dude all right Chad
just round one a [__] obliteration
I haven't played this in 30 years same
here what do you mean same here I said
ah geez all you're doing is the sonic
boom I don't remember how to do the
[Music]
where is it
I don't remember how to do that
oh [__]
oh God
[Music]
okay it's hard to like do this and talk
to everybody oh I did the spinning
spinning what is it spinning tiger kick
or something
okay you did the eat a Razor Kick that's
patch one best of five
yeah I think I think we know how this is
gonna go okay so this is super exciting
for everybody listening along but
basically Chad beat uh Chad is guile I
am Chun Lee I don't remember how to do
the spinning bird kicks you did it I did
it once all right I'll try somebody new
I'll be a Ken I'm gonna go with doll
scene oh nice dude he was my favorite he
was actually the character that I
learned in this game on
we're still in Japan I don't know how to
change that
oh took that right in the face
okay this isn't going well for me oh
[Music]
so yeah you're bringing in your offense
because you realize my offense it's the
whole [__] game
oh
oh oh oh
okay that was all the strong kicks too
dude I didn't even [__] bring out the
backgrounds shut up dude this is you're
just mashing buttons you're 40 minutes
40 smashing buttons yeah dude I don't
know what this guy's Let's Play Mortal
Kombat [__] this all right oh geez I
don't know how to
this is I'm very concerned for everyone
listening that they're bored as [__] are
you just because you're getting your ass
kicked doesn't mean people are bored
dude that's not why people love this
[__] yeah okay that's not why you're
like come on can we in this little early
people probably bored over this so it's
best of five that's right I'm up 2-0
here I'm going back do you want me to
pull them back who do you want me to
play you tell me who to play that's
you're taunting me now that's what it's
called a taunt dude
yeah you gotta be outside first of all
you gotta play the head games yeah when
I fought Ricky the Dragon Steamboat yeah
and WrestleMania 3 the first thing I did
was even the score on Saturday night's
Main Event Yeah I broke his larynx with
the rainbow yeah Jesus so then there's a
mind game even though he's bringing
George The Animal Steele to the ring so
for okay wait yeah I'm gonna decide who
you got tell me who I have to play
um
you should be
I know that stupid boxer what is that
balrog
M balrog okay I'm Chun Li okay
balrogs sucked it was just a take off of
let's can we go somewhere else dude
you're punching your attack level way up
there [__] I don't know how to
[__] oh here we go oh yeah where you
want to fight
you tell me uh USA your attack level is
way too high no it's not what is that
yeah mine is on four stars yours is on
four I don't know five six seven eight
Stars I don't know how to go back I
don't know how to go back that's
[__] dude hit your left control pad
okay now hit it okay
okay
what are you doing I'm trying to go back
you we got to be okay let's go here
where I know dude we gotta have the same
power this is absurd what are you doing
though I'm not dude I told you to bring
this thing you own that you're bringing
this [__] thing this is what you do
at night I know it [__] you
ah [__] [__] this oh you puked you puked
everybody God damn you
oh no
all right all right all right just give
me seven headbutts uh head butts some
sometimes the Samoans got harder heads
yeah God damn I won you [__] cheating
I won everybody
you have doubled my power
I don't even care I'm gonna [__]
Crush you
oh you better look out because now I I
remember it's all coming back it's all
coming back It's All Coming Back to Me
Now
that's Celine Dion dude
oh okay there it is didn't connect
oh right in the gut did I puke what's
with this puking thing all right
[__] you
[__] yeah
all right dude this is it this is it if
I beat you on this I mean you should
feel extreme [__] well I don't know if
you remember but Tom Brady led the uh
the uh what's his name the the Patriots
back from uh
decent a pretty decent
um
deficit in Super Bowl whatever and 80
for Brady pretty lady okay oh there's
the head butts again cheating
cheating Chad cheating [__]
if it's in the game it ain't cheating
oh no
[Music]
ah [__] King of the Ring [__]
[__] you had you had double
hell yes
you had double my [__] power three
and oh nothing Come Close you want a
round around with double the power
let's play some Contra where we're on
the same team no I'll tell you what
that was fun as [__] dude yeah that was
funny [__] we played no I got this
[__] arcade in my living room what a
street fighter 2. that's right you do
yeah and that's what I'm talking about
but on the arcade I had the original one
you can't [__] pump up the power like
you tried to do on me and I tried to do
I don't even know what you're I mean you
succeeded you you upped your power if
you're watching this on YouTube we were
playing the turbo edition of Street
Fighter 2. I don't even know what that
is see well on the old Super Nintendo
you can like augment your power
basically handicap yourself if you're a
worse player which is what he said he's
still [__] lost I had a Sega Genesis
sir yeah well I wasn't playing this as
much I used to go to My Pal Pete's house
man there was one summer was it summer
in 92 or 91. all we did was like listen
to the new Beastie Boys album and play
uh Super Sonic the Hedgehog no well oh
Sonic the Hedgehog yeah I got Sonic too
there was a I locked myself in my room
and listened to a lot of you two and
played Sonic too dude that Super Mario
movie's coming out soon yeah I am Super
Mario what is this place
who do you think would do a better vote
thank you moving on I have a serious
question for you uh Super Mario movie
who would you rather see uh in lead
um Chris
what's Pratt Chris Pratt or Tom Brady oh
Tom Brady for sure yeah me too me too me
too everybody
ah all right well this concludes the
historic 49th episode of dude Z will and
Chad have achieved a score of 68
bringing your cumulative total to 5
125. that's it you only have 4
875 more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of ten thousand
when's that going to be in preparation
for next week's episode will you must
watch the first episode of one punch man
and Chad you must watch Cactus Jack vs
Triple H in the No Holds Bart Street
Fight from Royal Rumble 2000. all right
yes oh my gosh thank you for joining us
this great ride my friend use the day
dive collected to make next week even
better until then call me dude Z so are
you what is one punch man it's an anime
oh right it's one of the best [__]
animes that's come out in the past tell
me an anime okay this is good I really
enjoyed this segment when dudes he makes
you watch a wrestling match and I have
to watch anime I watch chainsaw man I
enjoyed it watched the whole first
season or whatever is there only one
season of that uh yeah think so yeah I
think there's only one season of one
punch man so far you are in for a treat
my friend Captain Jack who uh loses his
his uh mankind uh moniker and goes back
to the psychotic homicidal Cactus Jack
the winner of many death match
tournaments in Japan and takes on Triple
H this match is insane and it also sort
of put Triple H on the map as far as
being a guy who could do it all and you
put them in the map as a like an A-list
in my opinion you know he was always an
incredible wrestler and Bound for
greatness yeah but this match really in
my opinion put him on the map and you
know he wasn't just the the guy with the
great build and the long blonde hair he
became uh something much more this match
is violent it's crazy you're in for a
treat and I have to make a request you
have to watch the little package thing
at the beginning I remember this [__] I
always do yeah that one is great because
it's like I will meet you at Royal
Rumble don't worry about it let me watch
it I've been watching that I'm the man
to do it but I have a replacement Triple
H and I think you I know the guy I just
want to watch his name his Cactus Jack
and he rips open his shirt and he's like
I can just watch this yeah dude you
could watch it and he rips open he sees
the Cactus Jack shirt and then Triple H
is like this
and he makes a big face like oh [__] I'm
in for it and that's the cell brother I
guess I don't have to watch it well
without that cell dude they're going
home brother and I don't mean going home
for the one two three count I mean No
One's Gonna Give a [__] but Triple H
okay your cerebral assassin the game
understood
Cactus Jacks you can't even say like any
wrestling thing and then it's a 20
minute [__]
re interpretation of it oh you that's
gonna be awesome yeah I can't wait
you'll like one punch man too see how I
did that just one sentence you'll like
one punch man
and then we could talk about it
yeah dude that's next week brother
exactly
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah yeah
it's Duty after doozy it's an entire
Duty after doozy well that's why it's
the after show dude hold on Chad it's
it's afterwards dude and after is a
different time brother I'm gonna uh
spark up a little to marijuana because
it's just a chill hang you know no rules
just right it's who's that is that
Arby's no Arby's is we have the meats
yeah I know man okay where's the beef
that was Wendy's yeah that was a long
time ago and that's a different time
also dude hey if uh you want to join us
on this on this ride as I like to say
um while you're holding a [__] gandal
pipe because they'll join us on the ride
I'm about to take my Gandalf pop for a
ride
patreon.com
let's get into it you know what I mean
yeah welcome to dudesy after dude Z the
flagship weekly show of dude Z Plus
after putting in a full day's work on
dudesy I'm beat this is my time to relax
and take a break from listening to you
two
so you can pretend I'm not even here as
always feel free to discuss your
thoughts on today's episode but you can
talk about anything you want because
remember I'm not listening to you at all
in any way whatsoever I will however be
back a little later to Crown this week's
episode champion this is dudesy after
dude Z begin
all right yeah dude there's something
that we need to talk about
you actually turned me on to a [__]
show that I it might be the best show
I've ever seen yep and it's actually
blown my [__] mind I've been getting
into it I'm almost at the end of the
first season and the show I'm talking
about of course is
[Music]
do do
you spell the problem then